[Music]
just moments after performing his own
set at the grammys
benito was sure to be seated to catch
dewa's performance of her hits
levitating and don't start now is it
ever
weird when you see your fans and it's
like some of the most famous people in
the world
yeah i mean it's for me i feel like
every day of my life tends to be a pinch
me moment
yeah i think every day i'm like oh my
god that's so crazy this is so exciting
or
um so i feel very lucky in that sense
[Music]
dua's five-minute long performance came
complete with an appearance by de baby
and three costume changes how excited
are you to get up on that stage tonight
and perform
i'm so excited
yeah i love performing so any chance
that i get to do it and i mean
today what how incredible is it that we
get to all be together in a safe way and
put a show on it's it's just a dream
come true so the six-time nominee
stunned on the red carpet in a bejeweled
butterfly gown
tell me about that dress this is um
a versace dress made for me um
versace made it for you wait a minute
versace
made it for her okay i love that um
butterflies have had like a lot of
symbolism for me this year yeah and
it's actually got a lot of symbolism for
versace too so it's really cool to get
to
come together and make something cute
making good on the promise of skin and
sparkle that she gave us earlier in the
week
my job is watching you arrive on a red
carpet and figuring out what design
you're wearing and what fierce look
you're going to bring so what
like what do we have planned for sunday
obviously we're ready of course we're
ready okay
uh i can't tell you well well i'm fine
are you going like angelic like
white ama moment are you going like skin
are you like do you have there's like
a bit of skin a bit of sparkle
a bit she's cute she's cute